good afternoon cs109 how are you guys
doing today
what I like to hear uh uh okay we have a
wonderful class we're going to do
exciting things and learn important
things actually debut a sense of how
exciting a day it is not only are we
going to be learning one of the profound
ideas that takes us from basic
probability Theory to being able to
solve very interesting real world
problems we're also going to get deep
into one of the historical mysteries uh
in the United States which is the
authorship of a particular set of
important documents called The
Federalist Papers we're going to learn a
little bit of probability has an
important theme to it and we're going to
be able to solve this cool Problem by
the end of today so a lot to look
forward to
but before we jump to that we're going
to do a little bit of review and before
we do any review I do want to just make
one quick announcement
the quick announcement is we have a
midterm in cs109 it's not next Tuesday
it's the Tuesday after so it's a long
time from now still we'll give you more
details about it but I just wanted to
let people know that
there's a lot of classes that have
midterms on exactly our day and after
talking about it amongst the head ta
team uh we decided that the most
reasonable thing to do was to let there
be two offerings of the midterm if you
can make either of them you choose which
one you go to you can either go to our
normally scheduled midterm on the first
at 7 pm or you can go on the second you
can go to the 8 PM midterm if you can't
make either of these you will have to
let us know so we imagine there'll be
few people who can't make either time
but if that is you then you should fill
out this form but we have just one small
detail that we need your help with
if absolutely everyone comes to this
midterm we would need a slightly bigger
room
so all we need to know is which one of
these you believe you're going to go to
and we need to know that by next
Wednesday if that's okay there's a
little form on the Ed discussion forum
please go fill that out just say which
one you're going to and if for some
reason you can't make it to either
there's also a form there for letting us
know does that sound pretty reasonable
okay yay
speaking about pretty reasonable some of
our review
oh we're in such a cool place in cs109
the cool place we're in cs109 is we have
finished counting Theory we finished
core probability where we learned things
like the law of total probability and
conditional events then we learned about
random variables and on Monday's class
we learned about the last major random
variable in our set of random variables
and now that you've thought about random
variables on their own it's time for
this beautiful next section in cs109
called probabilistic models what an
exciting moment
now the last random variable we learned
about is worth doing a little bit of
review on because it is pretty important
that normal distribution shows up in so
many assumptions and so many problems so
many times in the real world
so we learned about the normal
distribution the normal distribution was
the probably distribution that had this
Oso canonical curve this curve is in
fact the probably density function and
we also learned in class that often when
we solve problems we'll use this other
thing called the CDF the CDF answers the
question what's the probably the random
variable is less than an input number
it's monotonic because as the input
number grows the probability that your
random variable is less than it can only
go up so here's a plot of a classic CDF
for a normal
we learned a bunch of formulas but I
want to just focus on one for now
possibly the most important formula for
a normal distribution
if you have a normal distribution with
those parameters and you want to ask the
question what's the probability that by
a random variable is less than some
input you use this wonderful formula you
take your input you subtract the mean
you divide by the standard deviation and
you put that through this very important
function called the Phi function Phi
function is a pre-calculated function
which is technically the CDF of a
standard normal
every computer has a pre-calculated
there's lots of places where you can
find it uh printed out
and that's how you find the probably a
normal random variable is less than a
value it's so important that I wanted to
do a little bit more practice on it and
I thought instead of giving you guys an
easy problem I kind of want to show you
guys a bit of a higher water mark for
how hard a normal problem could be just
using that one equation I have given you
so far so to start up today we're gonna
go dive deep into really challenging you
on your knowledge of normals I'll write
down that equation that you guys
need to know
so if you have a random variable that's
a normal so X is a normal and it has a
mean and it has a variance
then the probability that X is less than
some value
is equal to Phi
of that value minus the mean divided by
the square root of the variance aka the
standard deviation okay you guys ready
for it
here's my problem I think it's actually
quite interesting um
it leads to a surprising result and the
result has to do with how many computers
do you need if you're running a website
and you want to guarantee a certain
amount of probability that you will not
be able to drop any requests
so the story starts on this uh thing
called singles day you guys have heard
of Amazon right
has anyone here heard of Alibaba Alibaba
is like the Chinese equivalent and their
Prime day equivalent is the thing called
singles day on 11 11. that is their
busiest day of the year
they will buy computers to host their
website
and they want to buy a certain number of
computers based on the busiest time of
year and they want to buy enough
computers that they're pretty confident
that they will not drop any requests
that even if there's more requests than
they expected they won't drop any does
the story make sense
okay let's talk about the problems of
the details
on that busiest minute of the busiest
day we're going to assume that the
number of requests you get are going to
come as a gaussian
gaussian might not be the true
distribution but people might just make
that assumption this is the Assumption
we're going in with
you're going to buy case servers every
server can handle 10 000 requests so
it's basically you have to think about
when you purchase your Hardware you can
your Hardware can handle a certain fixed
number of requests
then you'll get a true number requests
and if the true number request is more
than you can handle you're gonna drop
and we want to buy as many computers
such that the probability that we don't
drop anything is greater than
0.99999 so we want to be pretty sure and
just to start this problem altogether
I probability of no drops
is let's say R is the number of our
computers we buy K computers sorry
and that allows us to serve our requests
and R is going to be very simply equal
to 10 000 times
okay
the probability of no drop
is the probability that the true number
of requests that come in are less than
the requests for the computers that we
can handle
so this is the same as the probability
of no drop
or yeah probably no drop
that's just to start us off
as I said this is a little bit of a high
water mark we want to figure out this
we've got this equation I want you guys
to think about it definitely take
10 take 30 seconds to think about on
your own then I'm going to give you two
minutes with the person next to you
so just think about it
okay
talk about with the person next to you
how could you figure out how many
requests you need to be able to support
such that the probability of no drop is
greater than 0.9999999
how could you solve this problem really
just using this one equation okay talk
about what the person next to you this
is going to push your knowledge and then
we're going to solve it all together
okay
this is a hard way to start a Wednesday
but I guess I'm getting this like full
speed into probability pretty fast
oh man it's a little hard to get started
but um
you know one way of thinking about this
is
here I draw the CDF so this is the
equation of the CDs but here I'm going
to actually draw what that would look
like if you were to plot it and
somewhere out here you have this is the
mean
but
as values of R increase
the CDF of the random variable R will go
towards one if you say what's the
problem of getting less than a billion
requests well you know the probability
of that will tend towards one is R gets
bigger and bigger
at some point
the if this is on the x-axis R the CDF
gives you the probability of getting
less than our request so on Singles day
at that busiest minute the probability
that you get less than R requests
as R is really small the probability you
get less than two requests is basically
nothing
but eventually there will be a number
such that the probability you get less
than R requests
will be equal to 0.99999
and the way I wrote this up I actually
took a moment and wrote it up as if it
were
uh problem set question
and here's how I wrote it up
I said
the probability that R is less than r
that is how you define the CDF and use
the capital F to be CDF can you guys see
that is that too small font folks in the
back can you see
huh yeah
okay
so the probability that the true
requests that show up being less than
some input R that's what if CDF is a CDF
answers that question and we use the
capital f as our notation for the CDF
and we're going to try and find the r
such that this is equal to
0.9999 we want to find the CDF input
that leads to this particular
probability that's a little bit
backwards from what we normally do we're
normally calculating probabilities but
now I'm trying to find what input leads
to a particular probability
if I put in the equation for a normalcdf
it looks like this it's the Phi of
whatever the input is minus the mean
divided by the standard deviation
I know what the mean and I know what the
standard deviation are so you know I put
those two things into my equation
and now this is a little bit
uncomfortable
normally we don't have a variable on
this side of the equation normally the
thing we're solving for is on this side
of the equation but now we do we have
that r
and this is a bit of a cognitive leap if
you want to solve for that R you know
what you can do
you can start to invert this side and
the first step is you don't necessarily
want five of everything you want to do
the inverse five both sides so Phi is a
function that can be inverted you can
ask
what input into the standard normalcdf
would give you 0.999999 Phi is an
invertible function and there's this
thing called the inverse Phi
if you looked up what input to the
normalcdf gives you 0.999999 the inverse
5 function would tell you 3.71902
the inverse 5 function it's a famous
thing
like if you go to our course reader
you know you can even get a inverse Phi
calculator right there
uh sorry that's the Phi calculator
inverse Phi calculator here so you can
like
put in 99999 it tells you the value that
you could put into Phi
that would lead to four nines is in fact
3.7
and did I lose my work okay
so we can note inverse Phi is 3.7 and
now you just have one equation one
unknown and if you solve for R you get
that R is equal to that little
expression and if you say the number of
computers you need is that number
divided by 10 000 the number of
computers you need is 103.7 by 104 and
the probability that you will drop a
request is less than
0.00001 and the probability that you can
handle all of them is greater than
0.99999
that's pretty tricky
a bunch of you probably thought like wow
that's tricky I felt a little bit
comfortable about this idea of a CDF but
now you had me do this in verse five I
guess I'm pushing you guys a little bit
with this review concept but I just want
to show you kind of like a higher
Watermark of where you could go sounding
good questions clarifications yes
just as I'm alive and we're fighting
with r here is the number of servers you
want at Mass uh
yeah so R is how many requests we need
to be able to handle
and every machine can handle 10 000
requests
on the maximum
that distribution yeah so here we know
if we want to not drop requests we need
to have enough computers to handle this
number of requests that's a really fancy
number I think if you did 10 to the 6
Plus 3.7 times 10 to the fourth it's
just like a million
um and 37 000. so we need enough
machines to handle one million thirty
seven thousand requests
and then every machine can handle 10 000
requests we just divide that by ten
thousand
okay yeah
yes
yeah so you know I said
we want to be able to have a higher
probability than 0.999 what if I said do
you have to buy enough computers that
you have a lower probability than 0.999
you'd be like I'm gonna buy zero
computers and then you have a way lower
probability than 0.99 you've got a zero
probability
um but the equals is an interesting one
so if this question has said I kind of
treated this question like it was an
equals like there was a lesson sign and
then really quickly I just switched to
what number is going to make this equal
to
um and
I solved for that and then once I
figured out this is how many requests I
need to be able to handle I'd need
computers to handle more than this this
or more requests
um
I say exactly equal isn't
so necessary here
you just need to be able to handle this
number or more
it's technically treated the same as
probability of Big R less or equal oh my
God that's such a good question so the
probability that Big R is less than r
that is the same as the probability that
Big R is less than or equal to R
that is because R is continuous and
continuous random variables we think of
the probability of R being precisely r
as being zero though I guess number of
requests even though we use the gaussian
will probably be discrete but anyways
because for continuous random variables
this is true for discrete random
variables this is not true
yeah gaussian continuous okay you guys
rock thanks for playing along on that
very hard review problem uh while it was
probably a challenge you'll appreciate
it and like either on the first or the
second depending on which midterm you
decide to go to okay so that's the end
of practice I do have a little bit more
review the normal distribution also had
this other beautiful equation this
beautiful equation is not the CDF it
doesn't give you the probability that
your random variable is less than number
it's the probability density so it's the
derivative of the PDF or sorry the CDF
and we find that to be very useful in
cases that will show up later in this
week
um okay I do want to skip that here's a
funny thing you're going to need to know
if you're in a normal probability class
I probably wouldn't teach you this but
you're in probability
computer scientist class and I think
because of that this is something that I
would like to let you know about you've
seen logs before
if I have log of x that's a particular
function that takes a number and returns
me back another number
and log of x equals y is an equivalent
way of saying e to the power of Y equals
X so it's kind of the inverse of the
natural exponent you guys have seen this
before the reason I need to bring it up
though it's for two reasons One log has
some beautiful identities if you've ever
worked with logs it turns out if you
have the log of anything multiplied or
divided or to the power then you get
these very nice simplifications so logs
are nice to work with but there's this
really really important property
that if you have the log of a product
it's the sum of the logs
so if you have the log of the product of
many many many things it's going to be
the sum of the logs of many many things
and spoiler this is critical if you want
to be a computer scientist using
probability and the reason is it turns
out
computers have problems representing
very small numbers
if you start multiplying if these are
probabilities and you start multiplying
them together you get under flow issues
where your computer can't represent a
number so small like there is an actual
number there but your computer just
can't represent it in its standard
representation
but computers do much better when you're
adding logs of probabilities you end up
in spaces where computers can actually
represent those numbers and so even
though log probabilities wouldn't
normally show up in an intro probability
class they should show up an intro
probability for computer scientist class
because computers will be much better at
representing logs of probabilities than
probabilities on their own anyways this
is like a little bit of just reminders
will bring this up later again when we
need it
oh and then you guys we're going to have
some more good times with some counting
States you guys remember we were doing
counting some people were like no but
I'll learn it again before November 1st
or Wednesday November 2nd uh anyways we
did counting and we did things like hey
if you have indistinct objects there is
n factorial ways of ordering them that
will come up again today
particularly this one counting problem
is going to come up again today
one of the things you could ask in
counting is if you have n distinct
objects and you're putting them to our
buckets
and particularly you want N1 to go into
bucket one and two to go into bucket two
and are going to pocket R we talked
about in class how this is the same as
number of permutations of the letters of
say Mississippi where you have like n1s
M's and N1 twos and nrs's whatever and
this is the number of letters in
Mississippi and you can sometimes write
you the notation I just want to remind
you guys of that result before we jump
into today's class anyways we'll bring
this all up again when we need it
okay
end of review
so
thank you guys for following along for
my review session the next thing in
cs109 that we want to learn is this
beautiful topic called probabilistic
models when you go beyond single random
variables and you start thinking about
random variables being random together
it's such a beautiful topic it will
allow you to solve big problems with
larger data sets but even though this is
where we're going to go we're going to
be starting as simply as possible so
that you guys can build some
fundamentals because when we go from one
random variable
to multiple random variables thinking
about them at the same time we're going
to want to do so very intentionally
so we're going to start in the discrete
world and I want some motivation though
the world is filled with interesting
probability problems there's so many of
them and almost all of them involve more
than one random variable some
interesting problems just require one
random variable like maybe if you're
thinking about that ride sharing problem
that was just one random variable but
many things require many random
variables and one motivating example
I'll give you is WebMD health
this is an interesting website you go to
this website and you put in all your
symptoms and after you put in all your
symptoms it tells you the probability
that you have different diseases so you
could say like I have dizziness and I
have a one-sided headache and I'm a 30
year old male and it's like you probably
have a migraine but you could be having
a stroke and obviously this is a big
probability engine and it's got a lot of
random variables in fact it's going to
have random variables for every possible
symptom it's going to have random
variables for every disease and it's
going to be thinking about all these
simultaneously and in order to do that
it had to go from one random variable to
many at the same time which is where
we're going in cs109 we're not going to
start with WebMD that would be really
cool if we could make it instead let's
start with something a little bit more
straightforward to think about our good
friend dice
single random variables is like we're
thinking about a dice problem and you're
just going to maybe roll the dice let X
be the outcome and you can ask the
probability of a particular assignment
to the outcome
if your dice has different outcomes you
can ask what's the probably the x equals
one you can say what's probably x equals
two probably x equals three and we would
generalize it to this thing called the
probability Mass function and ideally
somebody would come up with an equation
a function a graph that could summarize
any query you could have about your
single random variable into one function
that sounds good
do you guys want to see what it looks
like when you have two random variables
well if you had two random variables
when we think about outcomes and events
the most common one and the one that's
most General if you could answer this
question you would know everything about
your two random variables is the
likelihood of assignments to one random
variable at the same time as an
assignment to the other random variable
so what we call the joint assignment so
x equals 1 and y equals six is the joint
assignment to X and Y
for
this is the full probabilistic claim but
you can remove the and and just put a
comma and most people use that sort of
notation
but if you could say if I roll two dice
what's the probability that the first
dice is the one and the second dice is a
six you know it's just going to be 1
over 36.
but more generally if you had two random
variables
the metaphorical equivalent of the
probability Mass function that complete
information function is what we call The
Joint probability Mass function and the
joint probably Mass function is now
going to take in two inputs
some assignment to the first random
variable some assignment to the second
random variable and it should give you
back a probability and if somebody gives
you this thing called a joint they've
told you everything you would ever need
to know about your random variables so
maybe that's the first major key when we
get into probabilistic models which
means you have more random variables
than one
the most useful information someone
could ever give you is this thing called
a joint
now the joint distribution for two dice
isn't that exciting because no matter
what assignment you have for x and what
excitement you have for B it's 1 over
36. well I guess assuming a is in the
range one to six and B is in the range
one to six
so
if you were to draw this one way you
could do it is you could make a
three-dimensional graph but a lot of
times we'll put these into tables
so if we want to visualize this most
important thing this joint distribution
we might just draw out the table and
that table has all the values assigned
to one random variable and all the
values assigned to another random
variable and then every entry here is
the joint probability that the first
random variable takes on this value and
the second random variable takes on this
value it's hilarious for dice because
it's just filled with 1 over 36. you
certainly didn't need to do this but
obviously we're going to be thinking
about random variables that would have
more interesting entries
questions concerns
okay shall we take this up into level
I want to just have us think a little
bit about this table and what properties
it might have first of all you need to
know what every single entry in this
table means so if I gave you an entry
over here
hey typo
I think it used to point one down this
would be that the x is equal to 4 and Y
is equal to 3 because it's in the y
equals three row
I put these typos in just to make sure
everyone's paying attention
but that's the most important thing to
know first what does one cell mean
okay
now that's kind of a boring random
variable one of the reasons or boring
joint probability table and one of the
reasons is boring is because every entry
is the same so I thought I would make it
a little bit more exciting
um this is real data that somebody
collected a while ago in cs109 not me
but now we have it a slightly more
interesting combination of two different
random variables run random variable was
what year somebody was in cs109 so
freshman sophomore junior senior and all
grad students we unfortunately get
lumped together like nobody even cares
about the nuances of our personalities
and then we have the other random
variable of their single in a
relationship or is complicated and at
least this is going to be like slightly
more exciting than dice to think about
this is a joint table so again you
should be able to think about what one
sells here means like if I say 0.1 here
is that telling me that there's a 10
chance that somebody's a junior
no it's telling me that there's a 10
chance that somebody's both a junior and
also in a relationship
and this is the complete information
that you'd want to know if you want to
think about a model that involved these
two random variables this thing called
The Joint
okay and that's your major key major
joint distributions complete information
you can actually answer any
probabilistic question you want to about
the combination of these two random
variables somebody gives you a joint
conditional question you can answer it
you want to just think about one random
variable at a time you can answer it if
somebody gives you a joint you have all
the information you need to answer any
question what a wonderful thing the
joint is
a couple small notes
for intuition
my claim is that let's say x is dating
status and Y is here
if you Loop over all values of dating
status and you Loop over all values of
years and for every single
um iteration of that double for Loop you
look up the probability of a current
year and a current relationship status
if you add up all those numbers my claim
is that it must sum to one if it's a
proper joint distribution
one way to think about that is any of
these cells is mutually exclusive is not
possibly both a senior and a five plus
you can't beat both of those at the same
time even if you're co-terming you're in
one of these and so each of these
categories is mutually exclusive
so you should be able to think about if
you want to think about either this or
that it should be just some and if you
think about this or this or this or this
or this or this or this or this it
should be that sum
and because they're all mutually
exclusive and they cover all possible
outcomes my claim is that if you summed
up this whole table it should summed one
yes question
always representative
that's such such a good question so this
joints uh probably Mass function if you
have two variables do you always
represent as a table that's pretty
common but not always and there's lots
of other representations which we'll get
into table is just going to be the first
one that we can visualize the easiest
yes
themselves don't add up to one what
that's such a good question why don't
the rows add up to one
if you add up this entire row it
actually gives you something very
interesting and very semantic
I'm not sure if it's apparent to
somebody but what happens if you add
senior and single or single senior end
relationship or senior and complicated
because they're mutually exclusive this
adding up is getting the ore so this or
this or this what's that describing
again yeah you describing the probably a
senior and is there one probability that
somebody's a senior
no yeah not everyone's a senior so
that's why it doesn't add up to one but
you're a little ahead of me because
that's one of the things I did want to
talk about in a second
okay you know this never comes up but I
just want to point out if somebody gave
you a whole table but they hid one
number I don't know why they would do
that you're like why are you so cruel to
me but they're like I'm just testing
your knowledge of this one fact you know
of course this would be whichever number
leads to the sum of one
okay that's not that important now
okay though this question is interesting
is so related to the question you just
had
I claim that you can answer any
probability questions so I'm going to
just start showing you that the first
one is can you figure out the
probability that someone is in a
relationship
in cs19 so that's just a question I
don't care about what you're there I
just care about whether or not they're
in the relationship could you figure out
that question uh from this table
think about why don't you talk about a
person next to you see if you come up
with a question I'm just going to give
you guys about 30 seconds to talk about
it
okay because we had such a wonderful
question
a second ago and you guys thought this
through hopefully this isn't so bad
first of all semantically if you want to
know somebody's a relationship
you don't care if they're refreshment
it's like this or this or this or this
or this and because each cell is
mutually exclusive you're just going to
be adding up these five cells so it's
this plus this plus this plus this plus
this if you want to be really fancy uh
you would write it like this you'd say
I'm going to sum and this is saying over
every year I'm going to add up the
probability where X is equal to in a
relationship and Y takes on each of
those values in the iterator of your
Loop if you add it up this is a fancy
way of saying just like add up these
five values
and if you added up these five values
you a good number which is the probably
that somebody's in a relationship and we
can eyeball it's like uh 20 uh almost
30. wait let's say this is 30 38 yeah I
said 45. so there's like a 45 chance
that somebody is in a relationship
you can do this for lots of things you
can say probably somebody's single you
can say probably somebody's a freshman
if you want to know somebody's a
probably is a freshman you just kind of
sum out the other way if you want to
know somebody that probably is a
freshman you some this direction
uh and that would give you the probably
a freshman if you want to know
somebody's sophomore same thing
there's a fancy name for this this thing
is called the marginal
and marginalization is like somebody's
giving you a probabilistic model which
has many random variables and you want
to extract just one random variable out
of it well you marginalize out the other
do you guys have a guess for why they
call this the marginal
not that you should know but it's just
maybe somebody's like I have a cute idea
anyone feeling cute
yeah
they used to like do this stuff by hand
back in the day before computers and
they would actually just write it in the
margins so you'd be like point zero two
plus point zero eight that's point one
plus 0.13 that's 0.23 and they would
just write it in the margin over here
uh and so that's where it gets the name
marginal and you'd write each of your
answers in this margin uh and in this
margin anyways fun fact not that
important won't be on your midterm which
could be on Tuesday or Wednesday
depending on your choice okay anyways
welcome to Marginal
um you know we can get really formal
about it and I used to teach people by
just showing people this equation be
like it's the marginal but I think by
now you've seen it on this real world
example I think it's a little bit
intuitive you know if you have a joint
table and somebody wants you to just get
one random variable on its own you just
Loop overall assignments to the other
random variable and you say okay you
want probably that X is equal to a let's
Loop over all the values of Y and you
get x equals a and Y equals each of
those values in the iterator
um kind of complicated equation for
pretty straightforward idea that you
guys already find intuitive
um and anyways that's what the marginal
is formally I did want to make a
connection to something we learned
earlier
earlier in class we learned about the
law of total probability and there was
this general form of the law of Torah
probability that some people found scary
and the general law of the general form
of the law of total probability says you
know if you have if you want to look up
the probability of some event
but there's some background event where
that background event has different
values and each of those values are
mutually exclusive and they span the
entire space
then you can extract just this
probability by thinking about the sum of
you know your event and this background
event your event and this background
event your event in this background
event it's the law of total probability
that has a theoretical justification for
why marginalization exists in fact
they're the same thing just expressed in
two different ways so if you found law
of total probability confusing but you
found marginalization easy you can use
that as intuition and the other way
around if you find law of total
probability easy that explains to you
why marginalization works so just a
connection that you might want to go
deeper into when studying
we've already talked about it why it's
called the marginal
so these joint probability tables
somebody asked is this the only way of
representing probabilistic models and
the answer is no it is a very common way
because it's very complete and very easy
to interpret but there's this key
problem they can get so big let's give
you an example
in our previous models we had two random
variables but we're getting into the
world where we want to think about lots
of stuff like that WebMD had way more
than two random variables so what if we
bumped it up to three random variables
so here I'm going to have a joint
distribution between three random
variables disease and disease has two
values either zero you don't have
disease or one you do
s is for smell and smell can take on two
values you either don't have smell or
you do have smell and F is going to be
your fever status which is you can have
no fever low fever high so we have a
joint distribution over a disease and
two possible symptoms
the complete information if somebody was
going to give you all the information
you need to answer any probability
question is the joint and in this case
that means they have to give you one
number for every assignment to each of
the random variables so D equals 0 and S
equals zero and f equals num there's one
number D equals one and S equals zero
and f equals num there's one number so
you need one number for every possible
combination now this isn't too bad
you've got one two three four five six
you have 12 different numbers
a computer can easily represent 12
somebody who's a scientist may be able
to give you those 12 numbers this all
seems pretty reasonable but where does
12 come from
12 comes from well there's three
assignments to F times two assignments
to S times two assignments to D so three
times two times two gives you 12. so
even though 12 is not scary that
multiplication is
fun fact if you want to marginalize and
just figure out what's the probability
that somebody has a disease you could do
a loop but this time not just over one
variable but over all assignments to
those two variables that are not disease
so you Loop over all values of fever
Loop over all values of whether or not
people can sell and say what's the
problem they have the disease and each
of my values that I'm currently looping
over if you add those all up you get the
marginal it works for more than two
random variables
okay
so great though we've got this we can
start to do some baby little WebMD how
cute
but we're like no our WebMD is going to
have 10 random variables or have like
four different diseases and six
different symptoms is going to be
fantastic and maybe each of those random
variables can all take on five values so
how many
unique assignments are there to the end
of every single random variable
simultaneously how many cells would
there be in a joint probability table
and a joint probability table should
give you one probability for every
assignment every assignment combination
to all your random variables so what do
we have oh a nice little counting
problem yay
okay I'll give you guys a second to
think about it
if you had one random variable with five
values
you'd need five probabilities
if you had two random variables and each
could take on five values you would have
a grid that's five by five that's five
squared
three random variables
you know multiply that puppy by five
because you need a grid for every
assignment to the third random variable
four random variables uh oh
what happens if you have 10 random
variables tiers all tiers just short
circuiting your keyboard on your laptop
from all the tiers that have come down
because five to the tenth is an
unreasonably large number
now maybe five to the tenth can be
stored in a computer but imagine the
poor scientist who has to think about
the probability for every single five to
the tenth assignment that's a bit of a
problem
and this motivates why we need models
like this five to the 10th combination
might be the perfect way to represent uh
any assignment to all your random
variables but we're going to have to
make some simplifying assumptions both
so that we can estimate probabilities
more effectively and also so that we can
represent them into computers because
even though five to the 10th could go
into computers you know what if you had
a hundred random variables that's pretty
reasonable and five to the hundred
becomes a real problem
so joint tables they're your be-all Endo
they tell you everything you need to
know but they have this numerical issue
in that if you have lots of random
variables they're exponentially large
okay welcome to the world of
probabilistic models
so
sometimes the structure of a variable
suggests a more efficient representation
than using a joint probability table and
we're about to start exploring those
because if we want to do cool problems
we need to learn more efficient
representations of the joint at the end
of the day we still want to represent
the joint we still want to have that be
all end-all we just want more efficient
ways than using this table does that
sound good
okay
I'm going to start with a problem where
there's a lot of structure and there's
so much structure we could represent a
joint using something way more efficient
than table okay here's my thing for you
I'm going to not flip 100 coins but I'm
not now going to roll 100 Dice and
you're like well we never did that
and the binomial would flip 100 coins
but we never rolled 100 dice one of the
reasons is because when you roll 100
dice some weirdness happens you don't
just have number of heads as a random
variable
you instead could have six random
variables as your outcome
number of ones number of twos number of
Threes number four is number five is
number sixes
do you guys see how if I roll 100 dice
that there's actually six random
variables that come out of it if I flip
100 coins and I say how many tell tale
or heads just one random variable but
dice have six outcomes not two so there
are six random variables someone who's
really clever might be like wait a
second if you tell me the assignment to
five random variables I can know the
sixth one uh so maybe there's a way of
getting rid of one random variable we're
not going to go there right now
but I want you guys to just appreciate
that if you roll 100 dice you're now in
the world of a probabilistic model you
don't just have one random variable as
an outcome you have six
just checking if we want to use a
probabilistic joint table how big would
that be
so you have six random variables and
what are the values that this one can
take on this one says how many fives did
you roll in 100 dice
can you get a zero
yeah maybe not that likely but you could
get a zero totally valid assignment
could you get a hundred
yeah like one in a billion billion
billion times you roll 100 Dice and
they're just all fives and you're like
what so the possible assignments to this
random variable there's a hundred
there's possible assignments this random
variable 100 if you were to write this
all into a table instead of having five
to the power of ten what you have here
if there is just one random variable
with 100 assignments
your table would have 100 entries if
there was just two you would have a
hundred squared but since there's six
if you tried to do this the naive way
and you just said I'm gonna make a whole
big joint table that joint table would
be just a bit too large
so you guys buy with me that this should
be something we should be able to reason
about
for a joint probabilistic model The
Joint probability massive Mass functions
what we really want to know but this is
too big
okay
we are now going to learn our first
probabilistic model that is more
efficient than a joint table but first
there's a question
right they should
I always
that's right
so it's so what you're saying it's
absolutely okay to have like probably
um you know during distributions that I
speak sometimes yeah and these are split
by one random variable
like if you say these are all the ones
where D equals one if you add these up
you actually get the probability that D
equals one
and if you add these up you'll get the
probability that D equals zero and the
reason I had to split it
was because with three random variables
it should actually be a
three-dimensional table and I can't draw
a three-dimensional table on a
two-dimensional screen so that's why I
split it yeah yeah very very good
question uh I bet a lot of people were
thinking about that and if I get to four
random variables oh my God is that a
problem I have to get into this like
weird uh splitting up of my tables
um but yes if we were super Advanced
this would be like a cube of some sort
with the 12 entries
okay
so we're going to learn for the dice a
more efficient representation and I
promise you this will go way more
interesting than dice just like a
binomial distribution became much more
interesting than just coin flips this is
going to tell us who wrote The
Federalist Papers and on that
Cliffhanger why don't you guys take your
pedagogical pause come back in two
minutes and we'll continue this
conversation about normal random
variables
okay let's gently come back
because a couple people went to the
bathroom
just before we jump into things can I
ask you guys a question
did any questions come up during the
pedagogical pause do you guys think for
two minutes you're like wait I really
want to know something
yes
oh my god um so let's say there's like
three options
in one variable three options in a
second variable
oh god um I'm gonna draw my Cube this
way
oh now you find out how bad I am at
drawing cubes this is very embarrassing
uh uh what is this supposed to look like
it should also go like three units out
this way
where you can choose your like X your Y
and maybe your Z
though realistically because I'm so bad
at drawing cubes uh instead of doing
this I would say
this is the equal zero
and then draw Z equals one and I draw my
three choices for X and Y and Z and I
draw Z equals two
and then you can imagine these three
grids
would be stacked on top of each other to
make a cube so this is like Cube level
zero Cube level one Cube level two
uh for anybody who's played
three-dimensional tic-tac-toe now it's
finally coming into utility okay good
question any other questions
okay
so
today we're going to think about a
beautiful probabilistic model called a
thing called a multinomial and it's like
the big sister of the binomial the
binomial asks if I run an independent
coin flip experiments what's the problem
of getting K successes but implicitly it
always assumes that means you get n
minus K failures and so coin flip is
interesting it's got two outcomes a head
or a tail
so like if that's a binary outcome and
this is the probability of getting a
certain number of successes you're
probably getting a certain number of
failures would just be one minus this
it gets its name from this binomial
coefficient and we thought about this
probability very deeply when we were
driving it
we're now going to be learning about the
big sister version of this called the
multinomial
and the multinomial doesn't think about
coin flips that have two outcomes it
thinks about things like rolling dice
which could have six outcomes
but you guys remember what we did the
coin flips we didn't always set P to be
one half the metaphor was much more
interesting when we let P be a parameter
of the binomial then we could answer
more interesting questions the
multinomial is going to use the many
dice rolls as its metaphor but just like
in the binomial I'm going to allow there
to be different probabilities of all of
the different outcomes
so the multinomial the big sister the
binomial it instead of thinking about
coin flips with two outcomes it thinks
about things like dice rolls with M
outcomes
if you gave me a binomial you would tell
me the probability of a heads if you
have M outcomes then dice roll at six
you have to tell me the probability of
each outcome well in this case it's easy
it's probably of a 1 is 1 6. the
probability of two so probably of
outcome two would be 1 6. probably
outcome three is one six they're all one
six for a dice roll but to make this an
interesting metaphor we're going to
allow for the creator of our multinomial
to tell us the probability of every
outcome on a single dice roll
it must be the case that if you add up
all the outcome probabilities it sums to
one when I roll a dice I'm gonna get
something
so if you take the probability of one
plus the probability of two plus the
probability of three plus a probably
four five six if you add those all
together of course that comes to one
so
in particular it describes a joint
probably Mass function where you have a
random variable for outcome one a random
variable for the number of outcomes of
outcome two and a random variable for
the number of outcomes of outcome m m is
six for a dice
C is going to say that you know we saw
this many of this outcome this many of
this outcome and this many of that
outcome
if you sum of all the CIS it must be
equal to n what was n again
is our number of dice rules in a
binomial it used to be our number of
coin flips now it's our number of dice
rolls so if you sum up all the CIS so
you had like two ones two twos if you
add up all the numbers of different
outcomes it should come out to how many
dice you rolled and of course as we said
before if you sum up the probability for
one dice of each of the outcomes it
should come to one
ins if you had this particular
probabilistic model you would not need
to have a joint table with a hundred to
the power of six outcomes instead you
can represent all of that joint
probability in a single equation
you just need this one equation you
don't need that mass of
um
you don't need that massive table and
this single equation looks a lot like a
binomial probability Mass function
it says what's the chance of outcome one
and how many times did you see that
what's the chance of outcome two and how
many times did you see the outcome two
what's the chance of outcome M and how
many times did you see outcome n
multiply those all together is not
sufficient because you have to think
about how many ways you could order all
of these outcomes these n outcomes C of
one of which are of outcome type 1 C2 of
which are welcome type 2 and CM of which
are outcome Type M
let's try a concrete example so I have
here seven dice so I'm going to roll my
seven dice you guys ready
rolling seven dice
oh my God that's exactly the same as
what's on the slides I can't believe it
if I count I got exactly one one exactly
one two zero threes two fours zero fives
and look one two three sixes don't check
please thank you
the multinomial doesn't seem that
helpful at the moment but just be
precise what it's answering it's saying
what's the chance of this exact set of
outcomes and you're like
how is that different from the chance of
getting like one of each
and maybe two sixes it turns out you get
different probabilities for different
assignments at different numbers of
outcomes wouldn't you know
and the multinomial tells you okay
there's six random variables being
random together it's a joint
and the probability that this random
variable equals one
while this random variable equals two
while this random variable equals zero
well this random variable equals zero
and while this random variable equals
three
we can think about that jointly using
just a single equation
the single equation says okay
what's the probability of a one I saw
that once what's it probably two I saw
that once was probably three I saw that
zero times was it probably a four I saw
that twice was probably five I saw Zero
times what's probably six I saw that
three times now
dice aren't interesting in that the
probabilities are the same here so you
know that was going to be 1 6 to the
power of seven no matter what you had uh
because I rolled seven dice but this
term will be different which says how
many different orderings can you have of
one one one two zero threes two fours
zero fives and three sixes so it will
change you know dice do have different
outcomes depending on different
assignments you put here
okay pause here questions is it making
sense if you roll and dice you now have
a way to talk about the probability of
out of the number of outcomes of each
outcome type dice are harder to talk
about because there's six different
outcomes not just two like a coin
yes
about what the first term is
representing that seven choose six
this one over here yes so this if you
were to write it out
B is the same as writing this is a
multinomial term and it's shorthand for
seven divided by one factorial divided
by one factorial divided by zero
factorial that's just one
two factorial zero factorial and three
factorial
so that term is the same as this and
this is the same way of saying you know
if you had you know how could you order
um two A's two B's one two three four C
D E one two three four five six seven
and saying you know how many ways could
you order these letters and you can
think of that A's represent your
outcomes of type one B's represent your
outcomes of type two zacom type three
four and five so the number of orderings
of those letters is an important part of
calculating this probability just like
the orderings in a binomial
random variable you know you take the
number of coin flips and you do n choose
K which is the same as n factorial
divided by K factorial times n minus K
factorial
so in the binomial you have this term in
the multinomial you have this term and
they are it's the generalization of that
binomial term
and the derivation for why you need it
is the same as the reason for why you
need that choose term for the binomial
good good question yes
the probability of getting this exact
world with guys yeah isn't that weird
look at the probably an exact roll of
dice where I'm talking about how many
ones how many twos how many threes how
many fours how many fives and how many
sixes and implicit in your question is
such an important question why would you
do this and it's not that important for
dice I don't think there's that many
games where like this is a really
critical idea
but it will be critical for figuring out
who wrote The Federalist Papers so we
will take this as a metaphor like the
coin flips was a metaphor like how many
times in life are you like I'm gonna
flip a coin n times and I need to know
the probability of getting five heads
like never but how many times does the
binomial showed up as a metaphor a ton
of times so the exact same thing is
going on here
okay let's bump this up a notch you guys
are ready
um just to focus in on one thing
these are all random variables and this
six random variable says the number of
times that six appeared outcome six
appeared was three and so that's what
that assignment to that random variable
means
um okay
and an important thing here is in this
equation
this over here would be the probability
of getting a six in dice it's one over
six for all outcomes but the multinomial
allows for the generator of the
multinomial to say what's the
probability of each outcome in which
case you would put the probability of
getting a six here if it was something
other than one over six
okay and you saw the six three times
okay great great we've done this sorry
we did the pedagogical pause already
I'd like to bump this up a notch and
actually make it useful
so we're gonna give you guys an
introduction to natural language
processing but first there's a question
example in the case do all the
probabilities even if they're even sum
up to one absolutely like if you say
here's the probability of alphab one
here's the problem outcome two three
four five six and you're telling me
there's only six outcomes from a dice
roll if I add up those probabilities it
must be one because they must be
mutually exclusive and they must span
all outcomes that are possible from one
dice roll
yeah it's it's this it's the multinomial
uh which is just writing seven factor
out of one one two
this is called the multinomial
yeah yeah so it's funny it's the whole
thing's called the multinomial
distribution that's the multinomial
function yeah I can see the pattern of
why the things on the bottom are why
what they are but I can't immediately
see like the proof behind it like why am
I just putting those numbers there and
why does that work
yeah good question
um you know when you did coin flips and
we did that very full derivation
it's like we're gonna have this many
outcomes that have one one one zeros
um zero threes two fours and so it's
like each of we have this many rows
where you have the particular outcome
quantities that we saw any one of those
rows has this probability because this
is the probability of that seeing that
one one it's probably seen that one too
they might have been in different orders
but multiplication has this property
that they're all going to come to the
same number and this is how many rows
there are so if you go back to the coin
flipping it'll be the exact same
derivation good question yes you said
that the binomial coefficient was like a
special case of the multimodule but I
don't really understand like the ad
minus tape factorial part and how that
comes from them okay
um
how many out if you think about the
binomial we've been super cheeky when
you flip end coins there's two random
variables how many heads and how many
tails
and if you have n heads how many Tails
do you have sorry so if you can't have
if you have K heads how many Tails do
you have and minus K so it's kind of
like there's two outcomes there's n
experiments two outcomes types summer
heads and summer tails
good question
yes so we're allowed to do for example
some characters together four or five
and six
yeah you could have one cat's Hall
outcome which says it's like a bunch of
these outcomes I'm going to put together
that would be allowed as long as you can
tell me the probability of that capsule
okay you guys want to take this to the
next level and do some natural language
processing
okay
so probabilistic text analysis starts
with a simple idea of just talking about
words that people could write on English
and for the longest time this was
theoretical but then the internet was
invented and we scanned all the books
and we looked at all the websites and we
could actually figure out probabilities
of words so you could take the entire
internet and you could think about
what's the chance that if you chose a
random word on the internet it would be
the word the
and we won't get into that exact number
because even though it's large it's
pretty small there's lots of words I'll
tell you that it's larger than the
chance of getting the word Pokemon does
that you guys buy that another fun fact
that you can tell your friends the
probability is somebody writing the word
Stanford on the Internet is greater than
probably somebody writing the word Cal
so you can talk about the probability of
any particular word occurring on the
internet
if you take a paragraph of text or a
document more generally it will have
many words in it strip out all the
punctuation and you can count how many
times each word appears you can say how
many times did caliper how many times a
Pokemon appear how many times did the
appear
you can think of those counts and if you
think about the distribution of those
counts we can model it using the
multinomial
and to give you a concrete vision
in our multinomial we're rolling dice n
times we're still going to be doing that
but now our dice is this massive Dice
and on this massive dice there's an
outcome for every word in the English
language
and not every outcome is going to be
equally likely so you have this big dice
with everywhere it's got Pokemon
somewhere it's got Stanford Summer's got
Cal somewhere and when you're writing
your documents like you roll your dice
and it says the you roll your dice again
it says best you roll your dice against
a class all you guys are going to get is
roll your dice again cs109 and the claim
is I'm just kidding the claim is if your
document has n words if you looked at
the counts of each words
then we could use a multinomial to model
it it's just like the dice problem but
hopefully more interesting
the one big difference is instead of
having six outcomes we have outcomes for
every word and the probability of each
outcome is not going to be one over six
or even one over M it will be defined by
How likely that word is to show up in an
English document
okay if people are curious there are
just a bit under a million unique words
in English it depends on the internet
defining word is a hard thing but the
dictionary says there's about a little
bit under a million real words LOL okay
so let's give you an example document
and this is a real case that people
first use the multinomial for spam
detection we'll talk a little bit before
that here's a document pay for Viagra
with a credit card Viagra is great so
are credit cards risk-free Viagra click
for free
this has 18 words in it
and so if you want to think about this
as a multinomial you might say Okay
Viagra showed up twice free shut up
twice wrist shows up One credit card so
twice and four showed up twice
now you could think about this as a
multinomial and it turns out
if you think about the probabilities you
could think about if somebody was
writing a spam email what's the
probability that they would write each
of these words and you get a slightly
different dice shape than if you take a
normal English language and you can say
what's the probability of seeing this
particular multinomial outcome in the
world where the writer is a spam author
in that case you know we can just use
the multinomial formula there are 18
factorial or 18 words so there's 18
factorial up here and then you do the
counts for each words that gives you
your coefficient
then you would say okay what's the
chance that a Spam writer writes Viagra
square that because Viagra shows up
twice what's the chance of spam writer
writes free square that because free
shows up twice and now we give you the
probability that someone would write
this if they were using the spam dice
and you could say also what's the
problem would write this if they were
just using the English language Dice and
hopefully we get two numbers and fun
fact this was the original spam
classification was based off of this
um okay
so in the world where you thought about
this particular author's dice this
probability of seeing the document was a
multinomial of counts of outcomes how
many times you see this outcome outcome
outcome outcome outcome and we can use
the multinomial joint probability to get
our chance of seeing this exact document
okay now we're not going to be doing
classification today we're going to be
doing something slightly different we're
going to be trying to answer this deep
historical question who wrote The
Federalist Papers
many of you guys might know what the
Federalist part sorry but if you didn't
when the US was just a baby country
they're trying to ratify the
Constitution and there was a series of
papers that were written to convince the
public to ratify this comp this
Constitution say like we should have a
constitution and they were all written
under the same pseudonym Publius
they weren't just one author it was
several authors writing these
foundational papers that we now think of
as a critical part in the history of
this country
but then later on we found out who was
Publius and does anyone know who Publius
was
James Madison Alexander Hamilton
and uh this third guy
look at the three people wrote all these
papers and this sounds pretty
straightforward and later on on their
deathbeds they're like yeah it was
totally me and I wrote papers one and
seven there's a whole bunch of them I
wrote 136 100 and generally that was a
fine way to figure out who wrote them
except on their Death Beds some of them
claimed to have written the same one ooh
drama
so
there's 85 essays as we mentioned
they're all written on the same Publius
but the real authors were these three
people
and we want to know who wrote each essay
and we're going to use probabilistic
analysis of the words and the essays to
figure out which of the authors actually
wrote it and I'm going to focus on a
particular one paper 53.
Alexander Hamilton and Madison both
claim to have written paper 53.
here is Federalist Paper 53 please don't
read it but there it is trust me that is
in fact Fearless paper 53 and over here
I have all the text from all the
Federalist Papers that I know Madison
wrote and here I have all the texts from
The Federalist Papers that I know
Hamilton wrote
and my question for you is can you tell
me who wrote unknown.txt
interesting
okay
where do we start this is your data
you're going to write a program that's
going to answer this question I've got
the data for us
and
you have to figure out an approach for
this
you have a whole collection of words
there's lots of ways of thinking about
probabilistic models of words but the
one that we focused on in cs109 in this
class is counts of words within a
document you know how many times does a
particular word show up in a document
these documents would allow you to
estimate the probability of these people
writing any particular word
and once you have an idea of like what's
the chance that Hamilton would actually
write divisions versus Madison's
probably writing divisions then when you
get over here you can think about how
many times a division show up here and
who which author do I think is more
likely based off of their probabilities
of writing those words we're not just
going to focus on the one word divisions
instead we want to think about all the
words that show up in known.txt
so you have all these words you want to
know the probability of authorship
and using the documents that I gave you
of Hamilton Madison you can know the
probability of any word given the author
this is a fun problem to think about so
I will give you guys just a moment to to
stare at this and think about what you
would do don't talk about with a partner
for a second and then you do talk about
it for two minutes
so just think for yourself
okay talk about it with a friend if you
want to how would you approach this
problem
okay
oh how fun
well hello again says pays and why does
Bayes show up here
you can think using a multinomial about
the probability of seeing a document
given a particular author
but what we would really like to solve
in this problem is the conditional the
other way around we want to know the
probability of an author given a
particular document and Bayes theorem
which we learn in our core probability
is also going to apply where you get
into the world of random variables and
probabilistic models
particularly what we would really like
to know is how likely it is that
Hamilton uh that the probability of
Hamilton writing this document given all
the words I'm gonna use D for all the
words it's my shorthand form
we don't know this direction but the
multinomial gives us this direction it
says if I know Hamilton's the author I
can talk about How likely is this
collection of words using the
multinomial
I have to have a prior belief of
Hamilton I have to have a this weird
term for the probability of document
what about prior belief that it's
Hamilton let's start with that because
that we can argue about
there's two things one could do you
could say based on my long history of
understanding The Federalist Papers I
have this prior belief that it's more
likely to be Hamilton I'll Express that
as a 0.8
or you could say I want to be pretty
fair to everybody so before I go into
this analysis the probability of
Hamilton is going to be 0.5 it's going
to I'm going to say before I look at any
words my belief as Hamilton is equal to
my belief that is Madison
I'm going to set that to be one half so
if you set this to be one half you can
think about this as the probability of a
collection words given Hamilton that
will be a multinomial and religious left
with this awful term at the bottom which
we'll deal with somehow
this awful turn at the bottom though I'd
like to talk about it for a second
because it shows up in Bayes theorem a
lot so normally if you have you know
probably H given d
equals probability of D given h
times one half
because we're going to say the
probability that he wrote it before we
see any data is one half
normally what you do on the bottom is
you find some sort of expansion for
probability of D and what we've often
done in the past is probability of D
given h
times the probability of H
plus the probability of D given Madison
times the probability it's Madison
and again we're going to say the
probability of H is one-half
and the probability of Madison is one
half that's what we'd normally do and
that's totally fine that's a good way of
getting rid of probability of D this
thing we call it the normalization
constant and we're all thin thinking
about cool tricks to get it to go away
this is going to be the probability of
the document given Hamilton
and we can just use a multinomial we can
say here is this document
we can look at how many times every word
shows up so this is the probably the
joint probably Mass function of the
multinomial
and it's got this multinomial
coefficient and then it has probability
of each word type raised to the power of
how many times that word type goes and
we're just going to instead of
multiplying the six times we're going to
multiply it over every kind of word that
we see in the document it will just be a
straight multinomial we can put a
one-half for probably of H but we still
have this problem of probability of D
can I show you something cute that we
can do
sometimes I just don't like that
probability of d so I can solve this
equation for probably of H given D I
could do the same thing for probably of
Madison given d
and in both of these equations I'll end
up with a probability of D and what if I
was feeling super cheeky and super cute
I'm like I don't want that probably of D
but if instead of thinking about the
exact probably of Hamilton if I just
looked at the ratio is it probably
Hamilton greater than Madison I could
know it by no dividing these two terms
we've never done this before
but you know I can take this term divide
by that term and if it's greater than
one I know probability of H must be
greater than the probability of M given
d
so I can calculate this term and then
figure out authorship does that sound
cool the coolest thing about that is
when you write these two things you're
like audio is probability of D I'm never
seeing you again and the one has cancel
out and you get that this ratio is just
going to be equal to
these terms one more beautiful thing
comes out this multinomial coefficient
is the same whether or not you're
thinking about Madison or Hamilton is
the author because you're looking at the
same unknown document and the same
undone document has the same count of
every type of word and those two
coefficients are just going to go away
and this whole problem is just going to
reduce to this
a very fundamental
um
a well-justified approach leaves us with
if you can calculate the ratio of these
two terms you should be able to figure
out who wrote this document how
to the code
now I'm going to give you
this calculation
I'm going to calculate for Madison and
I'm going to calculate the multinomial
I'm going to Loop over my unknown
document get the probability of every
word see how many times it shows up so
first this probability will be Hamilton
is the author writing word I then next
time I call this function will be
Madison the author work writing word I
and I'm going to calculate exactly what
I had on the slides and we will know
once and for all who wrote this
this is starter.py
now if you look at some things I just
pull out from the dictionary before I
show you any results
I first say I look up I compute
Madison's probability of every word so
the probability that Hamilton writes the
word Congress is 0.001 that's very high
I do not write Congress that much
Madison either Madison's probably
writing the word Congress is
0.00016 Congress shows up once in the
documents hmm it's looking a little bit
like Hamilton
anyways there is a
2172 words in this document and then I
calculate this term and I calculate this
term
we'll go over the exact details of this
code later
but when I calculate those two terms I
get the probability of the document
given Hamilton is zero
and the probability of the document
given Madison
is also zero
heartbroken I'm heartbroken does this
tell me who wrote it
is it because probability is zero for
everything no these should not be zero
probabilities
what has gone wrong what a mystery the
mystery continues come back on Friday
we'll figure the true
Ashton who wrote this document and think
about it in the next couple of days what
has gone wrong here don't forget let us
know when are you taking the finals